[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL BILODEAU: Today, I'm going
to be talking about Android
memory, and specifically
Android memory and games,
from a games perspective.
My name is Bill Bilodeau, and
I work with game developers.
I'm a developer advocate.
And working with
game developers,
oftentimes I hear
things about memory--
problems that they have
running out of memory.
So I want to talk about
some of the things
about memory and Android.
But specific about
one of the things
that I first want to mention,
before I go into that,
is there have been
some improvements in Q,
with respect to memory.
So during my slides, I'm going
to be showing this Q logo,
and that'll kind of help you
remember that this is something
new in Q. All right.
So what are some of the
problems that developers
face with memory?
The biggest problem is, of
course, running out of memory
and having your game just crash.
Now, Android is different
than other platforms.
If you take, for
example, consoles,
you have a fixed
amount of memory.
And it's much easier to predict
how much memory you can use
and how much memory
to budget for.
In the case of the PC, you
have a lot of swap space.
So if you start running low on
memory, a lot of that memory
can be swapped to disk.
However, in the case of Android,
when it runs low on memory,
about the only thing
that can happen
to you, that it can do about
it, is your game gets killed.
So it's not good.
So you want to avoid
that situation.
And I'm going to be
talking about that today--
how to avoid that.
Now, ideally, game
developers would like
to have fixed memory budgets.
It makes it much easier when
you're developing the game.
You tell your artists,
I have a certain amount
for textures, geometry.
You can set aside a
certain amount for code.
But in order to
do this, you need
to know how big
that whole pie is.
And that's the hard thing to
do, because in order to do this,
you need to know
the size of memory--
how much memory is available.
So in the case of
Android, you can set--
one answer to this question
is, as much as possible.
But that's still kind
of vague, because it
depends a lot on the system.
The system can't be
taken out of memory.
It still has to be
there, so your game
has to share that
memory with the system.
So what this means
is there's really
no definite fixed size on how
much available memory you have.
I'm hoping that by
seeing this talk,
and learning more
about Android memory,
and understanding how
it works, that you'll
be able to prevent the
bad things from happening,
like crashes.
Now before I go on, I
did this memory test.
I put together this little
app that allocates memory.
And every time you press
on this red button,
it allocates 100 megabytes.
And I was able to allocate
4.1 gigabytes on a device that
only has 4 gigabytes of RAM.
How is that possible?
So first of all, I don't
recommend that games do this.
You're going to run
into other problems
if you try to allocate
that much memory.
But I want you to
think about that,
and we'll come
back to that later.
So here are some of
the things that I
think game developers should
know about Android memory.
First of all, the Android
memory philosophy.
It's similar to Linux, because
Android is based on Linux.
It wants to use all of RAM.
If you think about
it, free RAM is really
doing no one any good.
It's just sitting
there, doing nothing.
So the way Android
uses all of this RAM
is to keep apps in memory.
The result of this
is you never really
have a lot of free memory
on Android devices.
So why do you keep all
of these apps in memory?
It's so you can do things
like fast apps switching.
If you have an app that
you started, and you put it
in the background, and
you go to another app,
you're able to switch
to different apps,
because they stay
resident in memory.
Now, the nice thing about
Q, a new improvement in Q,
is that we're doing very active
compaction of these background
apps, so that if you have a
very large app, like your game,
for example, you
can actually put
your game into the background.
Users can put your
game to the background,
and it'll still be resonant
and running when it comes back.
So let's look at some of the
specifics about device memory.
There's different
types of memory.
We can categorize
them by size, and also
by how fast that memory is.
So for example, RAM
is the fast memory.
It's limited in size.
It's smaller than
other types of memory.
One thing to
consider about RAM is
that it's shared between
the CPU and the GPU.
So they both are
using that memory.
Android devices also
have secondary storage.
This is where your
apps are stored
when they're not being used.
This is non-volatile RAM.
It's slower than RAM, but
you have a lot more of it.
So this diagram
really isn't to scale.
Another type of RAM
that I want to mention,
or memory that I want
to mention, is zRAM.
And this is compressed memory
that the system sets aside
for swapping.
So, go into a little
bit more detail here.
What are the different
types of memory?
Obviously, we have free
memory, free memory pages.
We also have pages
that are storage back.
So these are pages
that are stored
on that storage, that
secondary storage device,
and also are in memory.
Note, I just want to point
out, when I say memory,
I'm usually referring to RAM.
So I'm using those
terms interchangeably.
When I talk about
storage memory,
I'll usually try to
refer to it as storage.
Now, there's also clean pages.
Clean pages are pages
that are storage back,
but have not been modified.
And you also have
dirty pages, which are
pages that have been modified.
Anonymous memory, you might
have heard about that.
That's memory that you're
allocating-- that you
allocate through malloc.
So what happens when you run
low on memory on Android?
First of all, there is something
in a kernel called kernel swap
daemon, or kswapd.
And this is responsible
for reclaiming memory.
So it turns pages that
are used into free memory.
It does this by swapping
pages, or, in some cases,
deleting the pages.
The interesting thing is it runs
asynchronously from your game.
So here's an example where
we've got a storage back page.
It's clean.
We'll say it's
clean, not modified.
And as this pink rectangle here.
And let's say we want
to reclaim this memory.
So what kswapd does is it just
deletes the page, because it
hasn't been modified.
If it needs it again, it'll
just read it in from storage.
Suppose you have
modified memory,
and even if it was
storage back, you
couldn't just delete it, because
those changes would be lost.
So what Android
can do is swap it
into zRAM, so that
partition of memory that's
used for compressed memory.
Now, because it's
compressed, it's
going to take up less space.
So this is a good thing.
Android track of certain memory
thresholds, both low memory
thresholds and high
memory thresholds.
And it uses these thresholds
as triggers on when to do
reclaims.
Here's an example of how
kswapd reclaims memory.
Say your application
is allocating memory,
and this blue line here is
the amount of free memory
that you have.
So as you keep allocating
memory over time,
that blue line goes
down, until it eventually
hits the low memory threshold.
At that point, kswapd kicks in
and starts reclaiming pages.
So your memory, your free
memory, goes back up.
But you don't want to
keep reclaiming pages,
because some of those pages
you want to keep in memory,
because your game
might need them.
So it stops reclaiming memory,
and then if your game keeps--
if your game keeps
allocating memory,
this whole process is
going to repeat itself.
I also want to introduce this
concept here of available RAM
versus free RAM.
So I consider
available RAM to be
the free RAM, plus
any kind of RAM that
can be reclaimed by kswapd.
So another part of the kernel
that helps to free up memory
is something called
low memory killer.
It's also called
LMK, abbreviated LMK.
And for each process, it keeps
track of an out of memory
adjust score.
And the score ranges from
minus 1,000 to 1,000.
The higher the score, the
more likely to get killed.
So those with a score of
1,000 get killed first.
The ones at the bottom, at minus
1,000, have a very low score,
and are highly
unlikely to get killed.
So the background apps
have these high scores.
So they're more likely--
they're the first
ones to get killed.
Your foreground
app is going to get
killed if it has to get killed,
after all of the background
apps.
And the system is almost
never going to get killed.
So all of these
system processes,
they're not going to get
killed before your game.
One thing to
consider is that OEMs
can modify the behavior
of low memory killer.
So it can vary from
different devices.
Here's an example
of how low memory
killer works with a game.
So you have your game here
running in the foreground,
and it has out of memory
adjust score of 0.
And you have these other
two apps in the background.
And they have out of memory
are very score of 905 and 900.
On the right here--
or, yes-- on the right
here is a little chart
showing the available memory.
And we'll see what happens
when your game starts
allocating memory.
OK.
So you've allocated memory
below this 905 threshold.
It's a memory
threshold corresponding
to the out of
memory adjust score.
At that point, low
memory killer knows
that it can kill that process.
And because of that,
it frees up memory.
OK.
This is great.
So your app just keeps
on allocating memory.
Eventually, it'll
get to the point
where it hits this threshold.
And now the Chrome
app in the background
will get killed by
low memory killer.
If your game keeps
allocating, it will eventually
get to the point where it--
well, sorry.
It gets more memory back,
because it killed Chrome.
But it will eventually
get to the point
where it gets below
that zero threshold.
And at that point,
low memory killer
will come in and kill your game.
So that's how games get killed,
because they run low on memory.
Android knows that it has
to keep a certain amount
of free memory around.
And it'll even kill
your game to make sure
that that amount of free
memory is available.
Fortunately, Android does have
something called onTrimMemory.
onTrimMemory is a
Warning about low memory,
that the system is
running low on memory.
And it's a callback to your
game to tell it to do something.
Now, in Android P,
and earlier versions,
it wasn't that reliable.
There were problems
where it was not
signaling this
onTrimMemory, even
though you're in
a critical stage
where you're going
to get killed.
So games, or apps, may not have
been paying attention to this.
Now, this has been
improved in Q.
It's using a new trigger, now,
to let the onTrimMemory know
when to send this call,
when to the system
to send this onTrimMemory call.
It's called pressure
stall information.
Pressure stall information was
something introduced in Linux,
and it was modified by
Android to measure the time it
takes to obtain memory.
So if you remember, I was
talking about kswapd and low
memory killer.
These things take time.
And so, as the system
runs low on memory,
these take more time to reclaim
memory, and give the app more
memory.
So pressure stall
information measures that.
And the longer it takes, when
it gets to a certain point,
it will say, OK, now I'm going
to warn the app that we're
really running low on memory.
And that's where an
onTrimMemory gets called.
So I just want to kind
of summarize here.
You've got low memory
killer, kswapd,
and then you have your game.
And these are running
asynchronously.
And the problem
with that is things
tend to happen unexpected.
Fortunately, changes in Q, like
pressure stall information,
should help with this.
So what things
should your game do
to avoid low memory situations?
The first thing is
respond to onTrimMemory.
Now, we feel that
this is more reliable.
It provides reliable signals.
So it's something you
really should respond to,
because it's probably the only
warning you're going to get.
Now, onTrimMemory
still has high latency,
so you could be running
into a critical situation.
And it may take some
time for onTrimMemory
to notify your game.
So when you do get it, you want
to make sure you take action.
And I mean doing
things like trying
to reduce the allocations,
slow down your allocations.
Try to remove things
from memory, if possible.
Maybe if you've got a lot of
shaders resonant in memory,
you want to evict
some of those shaders.
Maybe you want to use lower
rez textures, things like that.
And also, because you're running
in a low memory situation,
you have a greater probability
that the game might get killed.
So at this point, you
might want to consider
saving the state of the game.
So if it does get killed,
at least the players
who were playing
this game are not
going to be so frustrated when
the game gets launched again.
And they haven't lost much.
So here's some Java
code that shows
how you can use onTrimMemory.
So in a main activity,
what you can do
is make sure you implement
ComponentsCallback2.
And then you just implement
this onTrimMemory call.
And notice that onTrimMemory
gets passed a level.
And this level corresponds
to the severity
of the memory situation.
So it can be either
moderate, or low,
and critical, which
is the last one.
There are a few other
levels, but these
are the ones I think are
important, ones I've looked at.
And in my case, the only
thing I did was here
is pop up a message showing
what the memory level is.
But in your case, what
you would want to do
is actually take action, and
try to reduce the memory.
So for Unity developers, here's
an example of a C# script.
And there's something called
application low memory
events in Unity,
and these correspond
to onTrimMemory calls.
So you want to
subscribe to this event,
and then have a
callback that gets
called when this event happens.
So Unity does have this resource
unload call which you can make.
That's one possible
thing you can do
to reduce the memory pressure.
So another thing that
games should do--
and most games do
this, typically--
is just to be conservative
about their memory budgets.
What things should you consider?
Well, you should take into
account the physical RAM size.
And also, you want to look
at how much, typically,
does the operating system
and system processes use.
In this case, it's about
one and half gigabytes,
and it's on a four
gigabyte device.
These can vary over time.
So remember, I was
saying, you don't have
definite amounts for these.
So that's where you
want to be conservative.
And you also want to look at
the maximum amount of zRAM size.
So as I mentioned,
zRAM is something--
it's used as
compressed memory, it's
used for swapping
when memory gets low.
So the more zRAM
that you can have,
the better your device will
be able to handle low memory
situations.
How do you tell how
much zRAM you have?
Well if you look in
the proc meminfo file,
you can see the swap
total is shown here,
and that's the max amount of
zRAM your device can have.
So in this case, it's
about a gigabyte.
If we look at some
typical games--
this is kind of a random
sampling of games--
on a four gigabyte
device, the most
that these games allocate--
these are peak memory usage--
is only about 1.23 gigabytes.
So they're really not pushing
the amount of physical memory
up to the limit of
physical memory very much.
Now if you can't be
really conservative,
the other thing is you
should be flexible.
So this means you need to be
more dynamic with the memory,
instead of fixed.
Of course, this
means you're going
to need to respond to
those onTrimMemory calls.
And because you're now taking
into account low memory
situations, and hitting
up against that limit,
you need to do more
game memory management,
and really design
your game to have
a variable amount of memory.
Now, crashing when
you run out of memory
isn't the only thing
that can happen.
So at some point, when
you have lots of memory
and everything's working
fine, and the point when
you crash because you've
run out of memory,
you could hit thrashing.
And thrashing is when you
have just continuous swapping.
The main symptom of it is
you have very long delays.
Frames could take
seconds to execute.
And then, basically, the only
thing you can do about that
is reduce the working
set of your game,
reduce the memory
footprint of it.
So here is an example of
how to look for thrashing.
We have this tool
called Systrace.
Hopefully you've used it
and have seen it before.
It's part of the Android SDK.
And if you notice here,
it shows processes being
executed on the CPU cores.
And you notice this one core
is just continuously using--
executing kswapd.
Kswapd, remember, is the
one that does the swapping.
It reclaims memory.
So when you see it active that
much, you should be suspicious.
The other thing to look
for is your processes
are getting into a state
where they're blocked
on I/O, because these pages--
remember, these memory back--
storage back pages
have been deleted.
So it needs to-- they
need to read them back
into memory when executing.
All right.
Another tip-- don't
allocate too much too fast.
So the speed of
allocations can actually
matter when you get into
really sensitive low memory
situations.
As I mentioned, reclaiming
memory takes time.
So you don't want
your allocations
to outpace how fast
you can reclaim memory.
And the result of this,
the game gets killed--
gets killed, potentially,
sooner than it really
needs to get killed.
Now I'm going to talk
about some of the tools
that we have for debugging and
for profiling native memory.
And I use the term native
here, of course, because we're
talking about games.
And this is memory
that's allocated by C++,
as opposed to like
the Java heap.
So one of the tools you can use
is a kind of a class of tools--
Meminfo.
And these are just
memory statistics.
So they include things like
adb shell dumpsys meminfo.
And that gives you some
statistics on memory.
And similarly, there's
something called
Debug.Memoryinfo,
which gives you
basically the same information.
Problem is, it's slow.
And the reason why
is it's collecting
what's called PSS storage.
And another problem is
it's not always consistent.
It gathers information,
say, of graphics memory.
And graphics memory is
collected by the GPU driver,
which is something
Android really
doesn't have control over.
And it differs-- it's different
with different GPU vendors.
They may be reporting memory
differently than another vendor
does, or they may even be
reporting a different depending
on the version of the driver.
So here's an example of what you
would see with dumpsys meminfo.
Obviously, it shows
the Java heap,
which usually isn't
a big part of a game,
because it uses native memory.
The native heap
is probably where
most of your memory allocations
are going to be coming from.
And also, the graphics
memory, because games
do a lot of graphics.
And it gives you the total here.
And I mentioned before, it's
slow because it's using PSS.
The other type of
memory is called RSS.
So what's the difference
between PSS and RSS?
So PSS is Proportional Set Size.
So it includes the private
memory that your game is using,
and it also includes
the shared memory.
So if different processes are
sharing some of that memory
that you're using,
it'll include that.
But it'll measure
it proportionally,
based on how many processes
are sharing that memory.
RSS is much simpler.
It's just the total pages
that your game is using.
We think that RSS is probably
more useful for games.
One of the reasons
is it's much easier
to collect that information.
It's faster.
The other reason is
it just gives you
all of the memory
that you're using.
Here's an example of how
those get calculated.
This game here has five pages.
Three of them are
private, just to the game,
and then to the
pages in yellow here
are shared with other processes.
So if we wanted
to calculate PSS,
we would take the
private pages, our three,
and then we have one page
shared between two processes.
So that's one half.
And then one process
that's shared--
sorry, one page that's shared
between three processes.
So that's one third.
Then you multiply it
all times the page size,
and that gives you the
total amount of PSS.
Now RSS, as I
said, much simpler.
We have five pages, and
then just multiply times
the page size.
Now one of the new
things we've added in Q--
this is, I think,
really going to be
useful for people who want
to trace memory, or track
their memory--
is RSS trace points.
And I mentioned
RSS is much faster
to collect than PSS memory, so
you don't have these delays.
And because you don't
have these delays,
you're not going to miss those
peaks where the memory might
reach a peak and then go down.
But you might miss
it, because it
takes so long to collect
that PSS information.
And it's great for this
new tool called Perfetto.
What is Perfetto?
Well, if you haven't
heard of Perfetto,
it's a new tool that actually
resides on the device.
And it collects
information on the device.
It can do things
like heap profiling,
which I'll show later.
And the really, really
interesting thing,
I think, for games particularly,
is it can collect arbitrarily
long traces.
So this means that
you can run your game
through an entire
level and be collecting
all of this trace information.
You can see how
your memory changes
with very high detail over the
entire length of that session
that you're collecting.
Some of the other things
it can do, it has offline.
You can do offline processing,
because it has an SQL query
that you can do on the data.
And you can collect an
information yourself,
and do your own analysis of it.
Also, it has a new UI,
similar to Systrace,
called Perfetto UI.
So to enable it on your device
in the developer settings,
go to System Tracing, and make
sure you enable Perfetto here.
You also want to
enable long traces,
and also trace
debugable applications.
Then go to the categories
section and make sure memory
is checked, because if
you're collecting memory,
you want to make
sure that's checked.
Then you just hit record
trace, and it starts tracing.
And you'll get
this notification.
And when you're done tracing,
just tap the notification.
Here's an example of Perfetto
UI for tracing memory.
And you can see how it collects
this memory information
about anonymous memory and
various types of RSS memory
over time.
So you can see how the
memory is growing over time.
So now that we have
these tools to collect
all of this information, I
want you to remember back
when I talked about
this test app,
and why does it-- why is it
able to allocate 4.1 gigabytes?
So let's look at
it with Perfetto.
If you look at the
memory over time--
and this is more towards
the end of the allocations--
we can see how the anonymous
memory, the malloc memory,
starts to flatten out.
That's the part on the top here.
However, the swap memory
continues to go up.
Now remember, swap
is stored in zRAM,
and zRAM is compressed memory.
So all of this
memory is compressed.
So even though it
says 4.2 gigabytes,
that 1.7 is all
compressed memory.
So it takes up less space.
So here's this app running.
You can see as I'm tapping
here in the bottom,
the memory keeps going up.
And I want you to notice here as
we get around to two gigabytes,
we get our first
onTrimMemory warning.
It says it's running low.
We keep allocating memory,
and at three gigabytes,
it gets critical.
I start to slow
down on the tapping
to allocate slower, and notice
now we can hit 4.1 gigabytes.
So it really does work.
Once again, I don't recommend
allocating that much memory.
More than likely,
you're going start
thrashing when you get
to that much memory.
So the other tool I wanted to
mention here-- another tool
is Heapprofd, and this
is also part of Perfetto.
It's used for memory
tracking, memory debugging,
finding memory leaks.
It's much easier to
use than Malloc Debug.
You basically just run a script.
You don't have to instrument
your game, so very easy to use.
And the other nice feature about
it, it has very low overhead.
So you can run your
game much faster.
It doesn't get slowed down
like it does with Malloc Debug.
Here's an example of some
output from Heapprofd.
If I zoom in here,
hopefully you can see this.
Every line here is an allocation
that hasn't been freed yet.
And it shows the
function associated
with that memory allocation.
So if you see some memory
here that's still allocated,
that's not free,
where you expected
it to be free, that would be
an indication of a memory leak.
Another tool that's
often overall overlooked
is Bugreport.
Now, when I say Bugreport,
I don't mean making a report
and sending it to us as a bug.
What I'm talking
about is the tool
that collects log information.
It's similar to something
like adb logcat,
only it's much more detailed.
And the really
good thing about it
is it shows low memory
killer activity.
The other nice thing about it--
it can be captured
after a crash happens.
So you don't need to
instrument your game
and expect when a crash
is going to happen.
If a crash happens, and
you just noticed it,
you then just take a bug report.
So to capture a bug
report, you'll once again
go into the developer options.
And you tap on this
Take Bug Report.
And in a couple of
minutes, this notification
will come up telling you that
a bug report has been captured.
And you can tap on it and
then share it with yourself.
Another way to do
this is to just call--
or just run adb bugreport.
And you can get the
information that way.
Here's an example of
a bug report log file.
And if we're looking
for memory killing,
we can search for this low
memory killer kill, and then
your package name, to see
if your game was killed.
And if you can see this,
there's a whole bunch
of low memory killer
activity going on here,
because we're running
low on memory,
and it's killing
those processes that
aren't needed so it can free
up memory for your game.
So in this instance,
yes, the game, the app,
was killed by low memory killer.
So in case your game is crashing
for some unknown reason,
this will let you
know it was killed
because it ran low on memory.
So just to summarize
here, some things I think
are good to remember.
Android, unfortunately,
has no guarantees
for the amount of available
memory that you have.
The things to look out for
are, obviously, crashing.
That's the really bad one.
And then, also,
thrashing can happen.
And that really is
bad for performance.
And I have mentioned some
of the new tools in Q.
And hopefully you can use them
to find out what's going on,
and prevent these bad things
from happening in low memory
situations.
And finally, I'm hoping
that now that you understand
how Android memory
works, you can
put this to use in your game.
Also, I want to remind people
that we're doing game reviews.
So if you have a game
you'd like us to review,
you can go back here
in the garage section
to have us look at your game.
And that's it.
And I have some links here.
In particular, you might be
interested in the Perfetto
link.
It's just perfetto.dev.
Pretty easy link here.
And also, in that
Perfetto documentation
is some description
of Heapprofd.
So that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]